>> So I'm going to talk about the financial
crisis and banking.
This is really not a recession.
It's a reset.
And it's not so much an economic crisis as
a crisis of virtues and
values.
And one of the things that we've forgotten
about is the power of the
idea.
And that's what America was based on, what
made America great.
It's what made every great nation great in
its time.
And so we moved from the power of the idea,
and using free enterprise
and capitalism to spread that idea and to
create value in society and
as a result of that you become wealthy and
powerful, maybe.
To just be focused on being wealthy and powerful
and so we made the
by-product, the product.
We made money the product and that's why we
hit a wall, and that's why
I say it's a crisis of virtues and values.
So I think the innovation that people are
not thinking about today is
really this global economic crisis as a reset,
an opportunity for us to
get it right again.
And in the 20th century the issue was democracy
all around the world.
And so you had movements for democracy, civil
rights, the hands of the
average person the right to vote, South Africa
and Nelson Mandela, the
Southern states in America with Dr. King and
my hero and mentor
Ambassador Andrew Young, his aide.
In India, you had of course Gandhi.
We still have the struggle for democracy with
the Palestinians, et
cetera, et cetera in the Middle East.
But in the 21st century, you got to have in
this global economic crisis
the backdrop for the global economic crisis,
the reset, the new issue
is silver rights, not civil rights but silver
right.
In this backdrop, if you don't have a bank
account, and you don't
understand the language of money, financial
literacy, you are an
economic slave.
And so we have got to make free enterprise
and capitalism work for the
poor.
So I think financial literacy called the language
of money, Operation
Hope, is the new silver rights and civil rights
issue for the 21st
century.
Operation Hope is doing its part in the US,
we've served 1,100,000
people giving them basic tools to help them
up and out of poverty.
Converting cash-checking customers into banking
customers, and turning
renters into homeowners, [INAUDIBLE] into
small business owners and
entrepreneurs.
The guy who made this suit that I wear today
and shirt I wear today is
an Operation Hope success story.
He came in with $35,000 idea, wanted a loan,
we gave my knowledge
instead, financial literacy knowledge helped
him get the loan as well
through banks vouching for his credibility.
He's now doing $800,000 a year in revenues
as a entrepreneur, has six
full time employees at Strobe Clothing, South
Central LA, and he's
paying his taxes, and raises his children,
and is a responsible
citizen.
And has started a nonprofit to teach young
people how to be responsible
citizens called LEAP, so he's leaping forward,
paying it forward.
And that's doing well and doing good.
So the big answer here, the big idea is a
massive campaign on financial
literacy around this world banks can use this
to get their brand back,
to get their reputation back, their credibility
back, to use this to
empower people.
And if we do this right we'll create a new
generation, a new culture.
And I guess I'll finally say my friend Quincy
Jones has issued 20 years
of change in culture.
In the last 20 years, we've made dumb sexy.
We've dumbed down and we celebrate it.
If we do this right, we'll make smart sexy
again and we will never end
up in this place again.